my name is fake and I live in the Dutch
cottage in rainy well it was really
really exciting at such a wonderful
moment to see the Olympic flame
once-in-a-lifetime moment pass the Dutch
cottage considering that it's raining
that the ton no has been tremendous it
really has a really good atmosphere this
is my Britain does excel in D smiling
rain
oh it was great it was tremendously the
people cheering and the youngsters
especially another had the day off out
of school is great to see the young
people especially enjoyable
I was a diver and my name was Anne long
in those days i'm now amperes and i was
in three olympic games it makes us take
part in it it makes the ordinary person
take part and get interested in the
people who are representing our country
and doing our best for our country in
sport
paranoid she looks about pupils to die
through that best for drug and proud to
be carries its own how does it feel to
hold that tool
you
I
I'm a tinnitus seems very to people
being honest once in a lot of time
together